so Justin congratulations on a wonderful
performance thanks so much what was it
about telly what made you want to be a
part of telling this story first and
foremost I was a bit of Ginsburg you
know it's a it's a story about her so
I'm a big admirer of hers and then
secondly of course the people involved
in the script did you have an
opportunity meet with her in person not
yet two days from now meeting her for
the first time what do you have planned
what are you gonna say you roll this
around your head and you just know that
if you plan anything it's probably gonna
be the wrong thing so I'm probably just
gonna you know keep my head low and be
and just try and be polite that's it did
you have an opportunity to speak with
mal wolf before no I actually had the
the luxury and I think of not we
couldn't locate him we couldn't find him
and we couldn't even get a picture of
him so we had to sort of create him from
whole cloth so I didn't have the added
pressure of like felicity of playing an
icon and having to get every sort of
syllable and accent right or mannerisms
or anything like that so yeah I kind of
just you know free wielded tell us about
having a reunion with Mimi and working
with her Oh heaven she's like such a
great filmmaker so it was um yeah it was
like we took a hiatus from leftovers and
then went in and started working on this
and we had a blast
why was she the right person to direct
this movie she's the right person to
direct any movie she she kind of can
direct a lot of genres so she can direct
action obviously she can direct
tearjerker II stuff drama yeah I don't
know if she's done a comedy but she's
just you know she's an incredibly
effective director and and quick you
know it was a 35 day shoot
she's just incredibly good talented very
talented talented director a lot has
been made about your leftovers workout
routine there's an army well you know
people have talked about it or um rvg
obviously has her I know I'll ask RBG's
I can hit the gym together cuz I want to
do her workout I've seen all that you
know videos of her working out and she
these are like no joke workouts they're
like oh she's doing like minute long
planks and you know and and she's kind
of amazing you know
I'm very grateful she's doing it I was
gonna say maybe she can outflank you or
something about it for a second tell us
about working in our beloved Canadian
city of Montreal it was fabulous I mean
it was I don't know I mean it's you know
obviously we shot there cuz it sort of
doubled for New York but it's wonderful
it's sort of like you know Paris if you
squint you know like and the food is
fabulous and of course the Canadian
hospitality which is not Parisian at all
you know yeah I love it there what do
you hope young women take away from this
movie the most or audiences in general I
hope they take away a curiosity and it's
gonna sound boring but I hope they take
away a curiosity and American civics and
understanding the way our justice system
works and even our government works and
the way our laws work you know because
you know one thing that Ruth Bader
Ginsburg was so determined work or as
continually seeks is the truth and it's
not it's not you know they're called
opinions when they render them but
they're not off-the-cuff opinions
they're very thought-out you know
intellectual arguments for why they
believe the things they believe you know
and she's her whole life has been on a
quest for justice and the truth and has
had been enormous ly effective and in an
era where the truth is clearly not
important to a lot of people I hope a
newfound respect for that is some kind
of newfound respect is appreciated when
they see the film what will be her
lasting legacy who knows
we don't know I mean she's she's I think
I've many years left in her and and and
yeah yeah you know that chapters yet to
be written well no in ten years 15 20 30
40 years what her legacy is
you